- Let's face it.
When you're trying to get God
to intervene on your behalf,
silent prayer is only
going to get you so far.
So it was only a matter of
time until someone sued God.
According to many religious traditions,
God created the universe.
So really when you think about it,
it's only fair that he or she should pay
for the damages that they've caused.
And in fact, the last part of a complaint,
the thing that starts a lawsuit,
is called a Prayer For Relief
and that is not a coincidence,
except that it completely
is just a coincidence.
So let's look at some instances
where people have tried
to bring God and Satan to justice.
The first is where a man sued Satan
and his staff for his own problems.
In 1971, Gerald Mayo filed
a class action lawsuit
against Satan and his staff,
because I guess like any
small business owner,
Satan relies on clerical
workers to dot the I's
and cross the T's.
Mayo, a 22-year-old inmate
at Western Penitentiary
in Pittsburgh, alleged
the following quote,
"Satan has on numerous occasions
caused plaintiff misery
and unwanted threats against
the will of plaintiff,
that Satan has placed deliberate
obstacles in his path,
and caused plaintiff's downfall.
And by reason of these acts,
Satan has deprived him of
his constitutional rights."
Yes, that is an actual federal court case.
Mayo had filed his
complaint in forma pauperis,
which in Latin,
translates to in the manner
or character of a pauper.
This allows for an indigent
party to get court costs waived
and is most commonly used
by inmates filing suit.
However, a federal court will still reject
a prisoner's application under
the following circumstances,
that the allegation of poverty is untrue,
the action is frivolous or malicious,
the complaint does not state a claim
on which relief can be granted,
or an inmate sues a
defendant for money damages
and that defendant is
immune from liability
for money damages.
Pennsylvania Judge Gerald
Weber denied Mayo's petition
on the third ground writing that,
this court has serious doubts
that the complaint
reveals a cause of action
upon which relief can
be granted by the court.
In a one page order dripping with irony,
Judge Weber detailed other
issues Mayo might have had
in regard to suing the prince of darkness.
Judge Weber questioned
whether the court even has
jurisdiction to hear the case,
noting that Mayo failed to
allege whether Satan even lives
in the Western district of Pennsylvania,
while noting that there
is no official case
in which the devil has
appeared as a defendant,
Judge Weber jokingly referred to quote,
"an unofficial account of a trial
in New Hampshire, where this
defendant filed an action
of mortgage foreclosure as plaintiff."
This was a reference to the short story,
The Devil and Daniel Webster,
where a farmer who sells his soul
to the devil is defended
before a jury of the damned
by famous 19th century
American statesman, lawyer,
and order Daniel Webster.
Though, if you're like me,
you're probably more familiar
with the treehouse of horror story,
the devil and Homer Simpson.
- I'd sell my soul for a donut.
- Which is basically
exactly the same story.
In this context, Judge Weber
noted, without deciding,
that as a foreign prince,
Satan might be able
to claim sovereign immunity
to shield him from litigation.
In rejecting this complaint,
Judge Weber also highlighted
another potential issue,
namely that Mayo could not
satisfy the requirements
to bring a class action lawsuit.
Under Federal Rule of Civil Procedure 23,
Judge Weber noted that
while Mayo might be able
to meet the first three requirements
of a class action suit,
the court was unable to determine
whether Mayo could fairly
and adequately protect the interests
of the class that he was
purporting to represent.
And finally, in denying Mayo's petition,
Judge Weber noted that Mayo had failed
to provide specific instructions
to US Marshals for how to
serve Satan with a complaint.
But this lawsuit shows why
it's so hard to sue the devil.
All these rules of civil
procedure were written
by people who are already
working for the devil, lawyers.
But then there's the
man who tried to sue God
to stop natural disasters.
One of the most devastating effects
of climate change has been the increase
of severe weather events,
such as flash flooding,
and more frequent and
destructive hurricanes.
And most of the proposed
solutions for dealing
with increasing natural disasters
involve regulating carbon
and shifting to renewable energy sources,
which are boring.
(buzzer sounds)
But in 2007, one Nebraska
State Senator opted
for a more direct approach.
Get a court order against God prohibiting
from any more destruction.
Enter Nebraska State
Senator Ernie Chambers,
who left office in 2021
after a record 46 years
in Nebraska's legislature.
Senator Chambers is no stranger
to standing out among his
more conservative colleagues.
During his career, he
would don a sweatshirt
and jeans instead of a jacket and tie.
And as an avowed agnostic
in the devout state,
Senator Chambers made no secret
of his lack of religious faith.
In his 2007 complaint,
the Senator accused God of causing quote,
"fearsome floods, horrendous hurricanes,
terrifying tornadoes,
and of making terroristic
threats against the Senator
and his constituents, inspiring
fear and causing" quote,
"widespread death,
destruction, and terrorization
of millions upon millions
of the Earth's inhabitants."
And Senator Chambers based his ability
to sue God as quote,
"that defendant, being omnipresent,
is personally present in Douglas County."
And in his Prayer for Relief,
Senator Chambers requested
a permanent injunction,
ordering defendant to cease
certain harmful activities
and making terroristic threats.
And in 2008,
Douglas County District
Court Judge Marlon Polk
threw out the lawsuit citing
Senator Chamber's failure
to personally serve
God with the complaint.
Judge Polk, referring to Nebraska law
that requires the plaintiff to have access
to the defendant for a
lawsuit to move forward,
ruled that God's lack of a
listed home address was fatal
to Chamber's action, quote,
"Given that this court finds
that there can never
be service effectuated
on the named defendant,
this action will be
dismissed with prejudice."
After the ruling, Senator Chambers,
who graduated from law school,
but never took the bar exam,
highlighted what he felt was a
flaw in the Judge's reasoning
that God had not been properly served.
"This court itself acknowledges
the existence of a God.
A consequence of that
acknowledgement is a recognition
of God's omnipresence.
Since God knows everything,
God has notice of this lawsuit."
Which is kind of hilarious
because substitution of service
through notice of publication
is actually a real thing.
But you might be asking,
"why would an avid agnostic sue God
in the first place?"
Well, he wanted to make a point
about the importance of
an open court system.
The Nebraska State Constitution
guarantees the right
of the people to seek
relief in the courts,
as provided in Article
One, Section 13, quote,
"All courts shall be
open, and every person,
for any injury done to him
or her in his or her lands,
goods, person, or reputation
shall have a remedy
by due course of law
and justice administered
without denial or delay."
Senator Chambers made clear
that he was not suing God due
to any specific beef with the deity.
And I remind you, he didn't
even think that God existed,
but rather his lawsuit was
a specific form of protest.
At the time, Nebraska legislators
were filing various bills
to curb so-called frivolous lawsuits
and Senator Chambers
believed that these laws
violated the Nebraska
Constitution's guarantee
of open courts, though,
sadly because this court
refused to issue an injunction,
floods and hurricanes have continued,
and God continues to evade
American law enforcement.
Which takes us to the time
that a hippie commune tried
to involve God in a fraudulent conspiracy.
The 1960s were a wild time of free love,
mind-altering drugs, and rock and roll.
All three of which could be found
at the Morningstar Commune
in Occidental, California.
But when Johnny Law came
to the Northern California
hippie compound,
after legal woes
and health code violations piled up,
the owner had a unique solution,
deed his property to God
and make it his problem.
Morningstar was founded
in 1966 by Louis Gottlieb,
bassist for the American
folk group, The Limeliters.
An ex-communist with a PhD in musicology
from UC Berkeley,
Gottlieb came to believe that
private property was a sin
and opened Morningstar to
create a welcoming space
for all comers.
Accordingly, Morningstar operated
under the acronym credo "LATWIDNO",
Land Access To Which Is Denied No One.
this 31 acre clothing-optional farmland
embodied the pinnacle of the
California hippie movement.
But if you ask the neighbors,
the compounds, tents, and tree houses
were a walking health, safety,
and fire code violation.
And soon, Gottlieb's legal
troubles began to pile up
with Morningstar's numerous
health and building violations
ultimately leading to fines
totally nearly $18,500,
approximately $140,000 in today's money.
- They're hippies, they
don't have any money.
- Sonoma County even ordered all people
to vacate the commune.
And in an effort to
end his legal troubles,
Gottlieb offered to donate
Morningstar to the county,
but was refused.
But then in May 1969,
Gottlieb came up with a creative solution.
He deeded the property
to the Almighty himself.
Gottlieb argued that
God owned the property,
so it was now God's problem to deal
with the fines and code violations.
But in July 1970, Superior
Court Judge Kenneth Iman
rejected Gottlieb's novel legal theory.
The law the judge wrote
requires that quote,
"The grantee must be a person,
either natural or artificial,
in existence at the time of
the conveyance and capable
of taking title."
And accordingly,
since Gottlieb could
not affirmatively prove
that God was a natural person or entity,
the Judge reasoned God
had no property rights
in the the state of California.
Judge Iman then voided the deed
and invalidated the property transfer.
And by 1971 bulldozers were sent
to level nearly every
building on the ranch.
Gottlieb passed away in 1996
and the land is still owned
by his heirs to this day.
All of whom are corporeal people,
actually existing in real life,
and show no signs of
omnipresence or omnipotence.
But you can get closer to
omnipotence by listening
to more audio books with
today's sponsor, Audible.
Even if you have no intention
of suing God or Satan,
you should listen to John
Grisham's new legal thriller,
The Judge's List on Audible.
It's the story of
investigator Lacy Stoltz,
as she follows the
trail of a serial killer
and closes in on a shocking
suspect, a sitting judge.
He's the most cunning
of all serial killers
because he knows forensics,
police procedure,
and most importantly, the law.
Honestly, I was gonna
make a joke about Grisham,
but that sounds pretty awesome and fun.
I use audible almost every day.
It's by far the best source
of audio entertainment.
I listen to audio books when I'm running,
cleaning up, or when I'm
supposed to be listening
to friends and loved ones.
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
all in one place.
If you tried to listen to everything,
it would take you three centuries.
And as an Audible member, you
get one credit every month,
good for any title in the
entire premium selection,
which includes basically every bestseller,
new release, or memoir.
Those titles are yours to keep forever
in your Audible library.
You'll also get full access
to their popular plus catalog,
which is filled with
thousands and thousands
of audiobooks, original entertainment,
guided fitness and meditation,
sleep tracks, and shows,
all included with your
membership, no credits required.
And right now Audible is
running a special promo
for LegalEagles.
New Audible members will get
a free trial for 30 days.
You can try it out and see why
everyone, including myself,
loves Audible.
All you have to do is
click on the link that's
on screen right now or in the description
or go to Audible.com/LegalEagle.
So right now for a limited
time, a free one month trial
of Audible, just by clicking
on the link that's on the screen.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist
over here with all of my other
legal entertainment videos.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.